Oh a legal immigration cost the US
taxpayers over a hundred and fifteen
billion dollars a year what price can
you put in helping your fellow man and
alleviating viewing suffering I don't
know the exact number
let's say the cap starts somewhere
around the hundred billion mark question
of the day is that just me or does it
seem that since the left can't make the
Russian collusion conspiracy stick
they've gone right back to calling
everybody racist that seems as though
they fit I don't know if it's just me
give me some some context everything
clip of Trump talking about ms-13 called
the gang members of a gang yes animals
and then the leftist took a snippet out
of context they claimed that he said all
immigrants for animals that clip just
went viral again this week for people
who missed it they're recycling the same
old narratives lies completely ignoring
the crisis of the border up to a hundred
thousand illegal crossings this month so
you say what reasons would justify
building a wall let me rattle five off
the top of my head okay and you can
share this with all your friends where
people say well give me one reason five
here with multiple source so make it
against a chrome is reason one I don't I
got lost my thirteenth all the time how
often have you heard this claim guys at
the undocumented immigrant a actually
commit crimes at a lower rate right well
let them say it but in our sanctuary
cities our people are not obeying the
law these are alive law-abiding citizens
every day immigrants commit crimes at a
far lower rate than native-born
Americans Wow seems like she went in and
said give me these 60s era Diane Keaton
in burgundy please oh my god it's the
kind of request that only the insane
limit notice the language here when we
would have the problem of illegal
immigrants they pivot to immigrants as a
whole that's every legal gun owners in
with illegal gun owners of course legal
immigrants are going to be less likely
to break the law because by definition
they're law-abiding their very first
action when they were presented with the
option to immigrate illegally they
decided to do it legally illegal
immigrants show they're three times this
is when you separate for illegal
immigrants three times as likely to
commit crimes
as other citizens they make up 27% of
all federal prisons despite being only
nine percent of the nation's adult
population choices it's no surprise it's
not that's not to mention by the way
every single crime committed by an
illegal alien it's one that could never
have been committed yeah had they not
been here illegally in the first place
so yes it's important to remember not
all immigrants are criminals but all
illegal aliens at least in getting here
okay okay reason number two how
effective a wall would be the lift tells
us it doesn't work but what a wall
really stopped them what the Border
Patrol says and I've spoken to a lot of
their people is look first of all if you
build a 30-foot wall all its gonna do is
create a market for 31-foot ladders you
know walls don't work argue down and
then they go on to argue for Border
Patrol here's an idea how about both
listen when I talk about the wall I am
talking about border security as a whole
the wall is really more of just a symbol
it's a pretty kick-ass symbol though
especially because it ruffles all the
right feathers it's Preval do work yeah
Israel for example cut a see illegal
immigration rate by 99 percent Wow
constructing unemployment seems
significant yeah yeah granted some
terrorists tunnels still a problem right
when Mexico has the destruction of all
United States citizens in its charter
well cross that bridge when we get what
we call statistically significant so and
I know I've heard these people arguing
that it's not a hundred percent
effective it's only okay neither well
look if anything at least stop your
cutting off the black pieces yeah what's
the opposite effect of murder laws up
what bankers Annabeth's anyway only for
white people turns me into a savage
animal like murder is illegal but it
still happens a murder laws and not
necessarily 100 percent effective
especially in your community
if a notification fell it's a little
blue I figured you could take it with
the viagra armor don't mug club a lot of
credit that come smokeless subscribe in
iTunes if you haven't subscribed already
apparently subscriptions don't mean
vacations let us know reason number
three cost Democrats have also been
claiming that the wall would be too
expensive not hold public employees
hostage because he wants to have a wall
that is not effective not effective in
terms of this purpose not cost-effective
in terms of what the opportunity to run
the numbers let's use it compares Israel
spent 2.9 million dollars I think yet
2.9 million a mile in their chance so if
we were to build a similar border wall
fence from scratch again not necessarily
a wall run us around five point six
billion dollars but let's use the most
liberal estimates total costs as high as
21 billion dollars it sounds like a lot
until you factor in studies that show a
legal immigration cost the US taxpayers
over a hundred and fifteen billion
dollars a years and I can already hear I
can already hear the rebuttal so I can
hear the argument what price can you put
on helping your fellow man and
alleviating human suffering I don't know
the exact number let's say the cap
starts somewhere around the hundred
billion mark we've thrown nothing but
manpower and money at the border and it
has gotten worse it is the exact
opposite thing of what we should be
doing so anybody who comes out and says
a wall won't work is doing it purely for
political gain is if you didn't know
that already but they're also putting
lives in danger go ask the people to
live on border towns my sister's
husband's family lives on a border tenza
pata it's not just at friends
girlfriends brother no and then he was
raped by a mess there number four he
likes it compassion this is what happens
all the time from the left this is not
unique here but they appeal to our sense
of compassion by talking about kids
being held in cages someone please think
of the children kennels
dog kennels for human beings this is
where they put them in it's like 50 60
degrees so you're freezing so how do you
show that you've been tortured right the
other word is banana in Spanish Bonita
is a dog cage our children effectively
as the senator said are being put into
dog cages right now what we are seeing
is the violation of human rights these
children and these families are being
held in what are called yella das which
are basically freezing boxes no person
should be maintained in for any amount
of time let alone the amount of time
that they are being kept on Milo the
first commentator says you know the
temperature is really low so these boxes
get cold and then Cortes just says
you're putting them in three thing boxes
that sounds like good air conditioning
yeah because when you're talking about
American Border Patrol agents who spare
no expense when holding illegal
immigrants they're going to crank the
air conditioning off yes in El Paso
these kennels they're fenced in areas
what the fact that Cajun kids started
under Obama I know some people try to
issue rebuttal so that well well that's
a whole topic for another but it did
start under Obama we're just talking
about the free sizzle the problem right
now is nearly a hundred thousand illegal
immigrants cross the border every single
month that's over three thousand a day
where do you put them yeah you have to
put them somewhere and it's not gonna be
the Holiday Inn Express so it's likely
going to be a detention center with like
you said fenced areas cage or a free box
it's pinson inna santa maria cortez
calls it but if we actually secured the
border that would be compassionate we
could avoid families being stranded in
these facilities in the first place it
would be the most compassionate thing to
do so if we build the wall and everyone
enters the country in a single-file
orderly fashion
oh that's if you don't you'll have a lot
of brown people sleeping under
overpasses in plastic and plastic Nassau
blankets okay the thing they're not
right they're not saying well we're
gonna do you think even the most racist
county sheriff wants to put a bunch of
Mexican migrants under an overpass
nobody does even if the most hey listen
chief I don't know put these brown folk
under the overpass you go
I'm racist but I don't want that PR
disaster yeah I don't want Don Lemon
down here to put me on a split screen
I've you know what I forgot what my
point number five was fours enough nice
friend number here's what's happened
we've pivoted of course from Russia to
racism and by the way wait for this in
the coming months as it relates to the
election we saw this remember when
everyone who didn't vote for Obama was a
racist and with Hillary Clinton everyone
all of a sudden became a sexist so
expect to see this with the Democrat
presidential candidate if the nominee
ends up being worn Gillibrand the
Democrats will start accusing you with
charges of sexism
that's Kamala Harris then they'll accuse
you of racism and sexism and homophobia
they're gonna try to paint millions of
Americans and law-abiding immigrants by
the way as racist and extremist that's
what they want to do right now all of
these reasons listed to the left to
people like Nancy Pelosi to people at
Cortes they think that all of this is an
extremist point of view and to you I
would ask put some more extremist view
than a nation without borders or laws
hey there Here I am drinking from my mug
in a button-down how often do you see
this never so do me a favor and yourself
click one of these videos playing in one
of these boxes here or a subscribe hit a
notification bell also because
subscriptions don't really mean a whole
lot if you really want to support the
show join my club if you don't then
there's no helping you